[Music]
amongst the chaos that is the loud house
stand a family that will go to extreme
lengths to protect each other this
hilarious and friendly gang never fails
to seize the moment but they aren't
exactly honest when it comes to their
feelings watch until the end to find out
which thought house characters are
rumored to have been dating since the
get-go new around here don't forget to
hit that subscribe button and give this
video a big thumbs up now let's find out
which southouse characters are quietly
crushing on each other
Ronny Anne and Liam Ronny Anne is a
tough cookie which is why Lincoln can't
keep his eyes off of her while Lincoln
doesn't care much for getting bullied he
endures whatever Ronny Ann throws his
way because well he loves her do you
guys remember when a kid named Liam
first started attending Lincoln school
if so you might recall how Lincoln tried
to befriend him and how things didn't
work out in the episode overnight
success Lincoln invites Liam for a
sleepover and the two pals seemed to hit
it off but before long Lincoln and Liam
have a major falling out but that
doesn't stop Lincoln from trying to land
Liam a date in Lincoln loud girl guru
girl you should get her chocolate all my
sisters love it oh cool so why would
Lincoln go out of his way to help out
Liam is it because Liam has a crush on
Ronny an and Lincoln can Barrett's this
could explain why the two buddies had a
falling-out could it be that Liam came
out about his feelings for Ronny Anne
and Lincoln had to put his foot down
well he might have a charming southern
accents this isn't enough for Ronny Anne
but that won't stop the redhead from
admiring her from afar Carl and low
allowed tongues of loud house fans would
love to see Carl and Lola get together
however Carl might have some other plans
at the sleeve no maybe that you want
that gotten my video let me explain
about the juju this character enjoys
being the best he never fails to tell
other people that they're not living up
to his standards despite all of this it
looks like Lowell aloud has a big fat
crush on him in fact some loud house
fans think that these characters would
make such a good match that they've
taken to writing love stories about them
on fan fiction well it's quite obvious
that Carl has a crush on Laurie the
loudest loud sister would never even
consider dating him but Lola sure would
these two characters are much
those are an age and even have a similar
personality but it looks like Karl has
an eye for the unattainable hopefully
this will change as he gets older while
it's true that Lola has a little thing
for her classmate Winston there's no way
of knowing if she'll ever make a move
regardless of this mini loud house fans
believe that Lola and Karl should be
together and secretly are do you think
these two characters will eventually hit
it off norm and Miss Agnes norm might be
your everyday normal guy but he does
have a lot to offer to the world not
only does he keep his school's hall
clean but he's also keen on helping
students whenever the opportunity arises
while it's uncommon for teachers and
janitors to fall in love something about
Miss Agnes Johnson took norms breath
away it may look like Norman Agnes first
met at the end of absent-minded but we
think that the two royal would
elementary school workers have been
together for a lot longer than that
Agnes is a great teacher but she has a
dark side that her students can't begin
to understand this makes us wonder just
what Norman Agnes had been up to norm
the janitor applies for emergency leave
of absence thought she might enjoy
wearing turtlenecks and little stockings
Agnes isn't one to stand down from a
challenge in fact the teacher admits to
having broken her leg while riding a
mechanical bull in the study muffin
episode although little is known about
the school janitor we do know that Agnes
is a spontaneous and secretive person so
knowing this we wouldn't put it past her
to already be dating him
the principal and his secretary it's a
tale as old as time the one that we're
going to discuss nonetheless as many of
you know Cheryl is the secretary at
Royal woods elementary school and she's
very good at what she does
thanks to Cheryl's abnormally large
hairdo and preppy personality spotting
her out in a crowd is a breeze all in
all she's the perfect woman for her job
but we suspect that she and principal
Huggins are more friendly than they
appeared to be despite being a strict
and angry character principal Huggins
has a soft side and we think that Cheryl
is one of the few people who can bring
it out of him this character tends to
butt heads with the loud children
however he does have a special bond with
Lincoln aunt Ilana for the most part
though the Louds have only brought
misconduct to his halls when were first
introduced to principal Huggins he's
evil beyond belief after some time
though his icy walls begin to melt and
he starts to reform his personality well
we don't have much to go on we believe
that he and Cher
have been together for a long time we
also think that she's one to thank for
his huge personality change tabby and
Liam tabby might be on the tomboy side
but that doesn't make her any less of a
woman sure she might enjoy playing air
guitar and turning it up to 11 but she
hates being lied to or ridiculed just
like anyone else in the episode dance
dance resolution Luna finds out that her
brother doesn't have a date to the Sadie
Hawkins dance
so she does what any good sister would
she sets him up with her friend
despite thinking that top he was amazing
Lincoln had bigger fish to fry so he
asked Liam to stand in for him and
pretend that he had an emergency to tend
to despite feeling a little let down
tabby end up hitting it off with Liam
and by the end of the night dorky little
Liam seems to be dancing on a cloud in
the end tabby ended up liking Liam a
whole lot more than Lincoln which made
her feel awful but after finding out
that Lincoln's emergency was a farce
she stopped feeling sorry about her
actions well we haven't seen much of
tabby and Liam since this dance we're
sure that these two characters have yet
to bury the hatchet
so do you approve of this loud house
couple or is it a little too shocking
well we sure hope it isn't because if
this couple surprised you you won't be
able to handle number one on this list
Agnes and mix wagger mick swagger isn't
your typical character and that's
because he's a cartoon celebrity this
returning character is a seasoned rock
star who always delivers a stellar
performance for this reason the
musically talented Luna boots him as her
biggest hero on more than one account
Luna has been spotted copy and mix
waggers fashion style and onstage moves
despite his fame and fortune Mick
swagger has managed to remain a
down-to-earth guy so much so that he's
often seen given Luna musical advice
while we don't know for sure we think
that makes swagger and Miss Agnes would
be a match made in heaven after all they
both have a wild side that can't be
tamed or understood while it's true that
Lincoln's teacher has a little crush on
the school janitor we wouldn't put it
past her to keep her options open after
all it isn't every day that you get a
chance to party with a rock God would
you like to see Mick swagger and Miss
Agnes get together because we sure would
in fact we have a hard time picturing
them with anyone else so who knows maybe
mix Wagner will pay a visit to Lunas
school
sometime soon collide and Lucy flag is
Lincoln's best friend so you would think
that Lincoln sisters would be off-limits
to him but that's not the case everyone
in the loud house knows that Clyde has a
massive crush on Lori
in fact his crush is so intense that
it's embarrassing hey beautiful
you take these stairs often whenever
Lori is around Clyde immediately passes
out and gets a nosebleed but Lincoln
doesn't seem to care about his friends
crash because he knows that his oldest
sister would never give him the time of
day but there's another loud sister who
just might lucy is by far one of the
most underrated characters this little
goth is Lincoln's oldest youngest sister
and for some reason she always pops up
when Clyde is around could it be that
Lucy has a little thing for her brothers
friend who we think so and we also think
that she's jealous of Lori's good looks
despite her hard exterior Lucy is
emotional and dramatic so much so that
she recites poetry in the dark for the
time being Clyde is preoccupied with
Lori but we believe that there will come
a day when he shifts his focus to Lucy
while Clyde and Lucy might be two
different people they consider
themselves to be allies so we're just
waiting for these two characters to come
out and admit they have feelings for
each other Lincoln and Girl Jordan
Ronnie Ann is Bobby's youngest sister
and much like Kim she's crushing on a
loud member but instead of telling
Lincoln about the way she feels she
chooses to torment him at school instead
while bullying or crush wasn't the
brightest ideas she ever had it did help
her to get on Lincoln's radar despite
flirting with each other for a long time
these two characters never ended up
dating for real which makes us think
that they simply aren't meant to be
so if Lincoln doesn't like rowdy Ann who
does he like we put our money on girl
Jordan and here's why she's Lincoln's
only other girlfriend she's nice she's
pretty and she's good at sports while
this isn't what people usually look for
in a girlfriend it's what an 11 year old
is attracted to while many of you think
that Ronnie Ann and Lincoln will end up
together we think that Lincoln will have
a change of heart after some time girl
Jordan is competitive and wild which is
something that Lincoln admires much like
Ronnie and girl Jordan bullies the
people that she likes and she's been
known to hit Lincoln from time to time
want to know why we think these two will
end up together well it's because
Lincoln gave her is pudding Cup at the
end of the be Stella my heart episode
and
let's face it you don't give away your
pudding cup to just anybody
Luna and Sam Luna is a free spirit who
loves her guitar more than anything in
the world she's young she's talented and
she's feisty making her the perfect
candidate for stardom she may only be 15
years old but she knows who she is and
isn't afraid to go after what or who she
wants it was recently announced in
Ella's her love that Luna was indeed
bisexual it's definitely the truth came
out when she professed her feelings to
her bandmate Sam sharp while we were led
to believe that Sam was a boy at first
it soon became obvious that she's not
while the relationship was recently
ousted some not house fans saw it coming
from a mile away
sure some cartoons don't include LGBTQ
relationships but loud house is more
than happy to broadcasts love in every
shape and form this is clearly showcased
by the fact that Clyde's parents hail
from his same gender relationship while
there's no way of knowing if Luna and
Sam will start dating exclusively you
suspect that they will Bobby and Lenny
by now we all know that Bobby and Louie
are joined at the hip however we don't
think that their teenage romance will
last forever Bobby is a sweet person who
is always there for the people he loves
however Laurie tends to put her needs
before everyone else's she's jealous
bossy selfish and can be incredibly me
when she wants to be her attitude issues
have often come between her and Bobby
which is why we're confident that their
relationship won't last despite not
being there's a lot of scenes together
Bobby and Lenny's seem to get along
exceptionally well so much so that Lauri
is afraid that you'll fall in love with
her in fact it was confirmed that Lauri
had the sphere in the butterfly effect
episode despite being confident and
narcissistic Lauri is a bit intimidated
by Lenny's golden personality well we
don't think that Lenny would date her
sister's ex-boyfriend sometimes feelings
don't leave any room for common sense do
you think that Bobby and Lenny have
liked each other from the get-go because
we sure do do you have a favorite loud
house couple if so let us know who they
are and why you love them in the
comments and that's the end of our video
thanks for watching and see you next
time on the things
[Music]